[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much everything
[Applause]
sorry to keep you waiting complicated
business complicated
[Applause]
thank you very much
[Music]
I've just received a call from Secretary
Clinton
she congratulated us it's about us on
our victory and I congratulated her and
her family on a very very hard-fought
campaign I mean she she fought very hard
Hillary has worked very long and very
hard over a long period of time and we
owe her a major debt of gratitude for
her service to our country I mean that
very sincerely now it's time for America
to bind the wounds of division have to
get together to all Republicans and
Democrats and independents across this
nation I say it is time for us to come
together as one United people style I
pledge to every citizen of our land that
I will be President for all Americans
and this is so important to me
for those who have chosen not to support
me in the past of which there were a few
people I'm reaching out to you for your
guidance and your help so that we can
work together and unify our great
country as I've said from the beginning
ours was not a campaign but rather an
incredible and great movement made up of
millions of hard-working men and women
who love their country and want a better
brighter future for themselves and for
their family it's a movement comprised
of Americans from all races religions
backgrounds and beliefs who want and
expect our government to serve the
people and serve the people it will
working together we will begin the
urgent task of rebuilding our nation and
renewing the American dream I've spent
my entire life and business looking at
the untapped potential in projects and
in people all over the world that is now
what I want to do for our country
tremendous potential I've got to know
our country so well tremendous potential
it's going to be a beautiful thing every
single America will have the opportunity
to realize his or her fullest potential
their forgotten men and women of our
country will be forgotten no longer
we are going to fix our inner cities and
rebuild our highways bridges tunnels
airports schools hospitals we're going
to rebuild our infrastructure which will
become by the way second to none and we
will put millions of our people to work
as we rebuild it
we will also finally take care of our
great veterans we've been so loyal and
I've got to know so many over this
18-month journey the time I've spent
with them during this campaign has been
among my greatest honors our veterans
are incredible people we will embark
upon a project of national growth and
renewal
I will harness the creative talents of
our people and we will call upon the
best and brightest to leverage their
tremendous talent for the benefit of all
it's going to happen we have a great
economic plan we will double our growth
and have the strongest economy anywhere
in the world at the same time we will
get along with all other nations willing
to get along with us and we'll be I'll
have great relationships we expect to
have great great relationships no dream
is too big no challenge is too great
nothing we want for our future is beyond
our reach America will no longer settle
for anything less than the best
we must reclaim country's destiny and
dream big and bold and daring we have to
do that we're going to dream of things
for our country and beautiful things and
successful things once again I want to
tell the world community that while we
will always put America's interests
first we will deal fairly
with everyone with everyone all people
and all other nations we will seek
common ground not hostility a
partnership not conflict and now I'd
like to take this moment to thank some
of the people who really helped me with
this what they are calling tonight very
very historic victory first I want to
thank my parents who I know are looking
down on me right now great people I've
learned so much from them they were
wonderful in every regard I had truly
great parents I also want to thank my
sisters Mary Ann and Elizabeth we're
here with us tonight and where are they
they're here someplace
they're very shy actually and my brother
Robert my great friend where is Robert
where is Robert my brother Robert and
they should all be on this stage but
that's okay they are great and also my
late brother Fred great guy fantastic
fantastic family I was very lucky
great brothers sisters great
unbelievable parents to Melania and Don
and Ivanka and Eric and Tiffany
and baron
I love you and I thank you and
especially for putting up with all of
those hours this was tough this was
tough this political stuff is nasty and
it's tough so I want to thank my family
very much really fantastic thank you all
thank you all and Lera unbelievable job
unbelievable Vanessa thank you thank you
very much what a great group you've all
given me such incredible support and I
will tell you that we have a large group
of people you know they kept saying we
have a small staff that's so small look
at all the people that we have look at
all of these people and Kellyanne and
Chris and Rudy and Steve and David we
have got we have got tremendously
talented people up here and I want to
tell you it's been it's been very very
special I want to give a very special
thanks to our former Mayor Rudy Giuliani
unbelievable
unbelievable he traveled with us and he
went through meeting me that Rudy never
changed it where's Rudy where is it Rudy
Governor Chris Christie folks was humble
thank you for the first man first
senator for his major major politician
and let me tell you he is highly
respected in Washington because he's as
smart as you get Senator Jeff Sessions
great man
another great man very tough competitor
he was not easy he was not easy who is
that is that the mare that shut up Rudy
Oh Rudy got up here another great man
who has been really a friend to me but
I'll tell you I got to know him as a
competitor because he was one of the
folks that was negotiating to go against
those Democrats dr. ben Carson where's
Ben where's Ben
and by the way Mike Huckabee is here
someplace and he's Santa
Mike and his family Sarah thank you very
much general Mike Flynn where is Matt
and general Kellogg we have over 200
generals and admirals that have endorsed
our campaign and there's special people
and it's really an honor we have 22
Congressional Medal of Honor recipients
we have just tremendous people a very
special person who believed me and you
know I'd read reports that I wasn't
getting along with him I never had a bad
second with him he's an unbelievable
star he is that's right how did you
possibly guess so
let me tell you about Reince and I've
said this I said rights and I know it I
know it look at all those people over
there I know it rights is a superstar
but I said they can't call you a
superstar rights unless we win because
you can't be called a superstar like
Secretariat if Secretariat came in
second Secretariat would not have that
big beautiful bronze bus at the track at
Belmont but I'll tell you rights is
really a star and he is the
hardest-working guy
and in a certain way I did this rights
come up here where is right get over
here oh boy oh boy oh boy it's about
time you did this right oh my god
Sasa ladies and gentlemen the next
president of the United States Donald
Trump thank you it's been an honor god
bless
thank God amazing guy our partnership
with the RNC was so important to the
success and what we've done so I also
have to say I've gotten to know some
incredible people the Secret Service
people they're tough
and they're smart and they're sharp and
I don't want to mess around with them I
can tell you and when I want to go and
wave to a big group of people and they
rip me down and put me back down to the
seat but they are fantastic people so I
want to thank the Secret Service
and law enforcement in New York City
they're here tonight these are
spectacular people sometimes
underappreciated unfortunately but we
appreciate them we know what they go
through so it's been what they call a
historic event but to be really historic
we have to do a great job and I promise
you that I will not let you down we will
do a great job great job I look very
much forward to being your president and
hopefully at the end of two years or
three years or four years or maybe even
eight years you will say so many of you
work so hard for us but you will say
that you will say that that was
something that you really were very
proud to do and and I can thank you very
much and I can only say that while the
campaign is over our work on this
movement is now really just beginning
we're going to get to work immediately
for the American people and we're going
to be doing a job that hopefully you
will be so proud of your president
you'll be so proud again it's my honor
was an amazing evening it's been an
amazing two-year period and I love this
thank you very much thank you to Mike
Pence thank you